だったら仏教の漢字だったら自分が出してるで結構です
わかりますね で 耳に何か触れたら耳で何か感じる
体に触れたら体に感じる
触れても感じなきゃそこで認識が生まれません
それは我々にとっては問題にはならないんです
光にしてもいろいろ光あるでしょうに
我々はそれは知らないんです
知らないんだから それは問題にはならない
赤外線だから煩悩が生まれたとか
人と喧嘩しましたとか
そういうことはないんだから
目に入る光にとって感じるんだから
いろいろ問題が生まれるんですね
いろんな音はあるんだけど
我々知らないし 聞いてないし
我々問題を作るのは目で触れて感じる音について
感じないものはただ触れてそのまま流れて
それ物体に触れたことと同じなんですね
だから私の音は皆様の耳にも触れるし
この机にも触れるんだけど
で 音は耳で感じるんだけど
体では感じない 音ってエネルギーだから体に触れますよ
でも耳にヘッドフォンにステレオでもつけておけば
私の音は耳では感じないんですね
体にもものすごく触れてるのに
そうすると何喋ってるかとわからなくなっちゃう
わからない 関係ない 触れたものは感じてないんだから
だから医者が手術するときは麻酔をするんですね
それでどういう働きかというと
触れることは触れるんだけど
触れるものは感じないようにする
そうすると認識が生まれません
だから体切っているのに
その人は生きているのに全然知らない
怖がらない 感じないんだから
ですから 認識の場合は 2番目に大事なのは感じること
受・ヴェーダナー そこで 3番目サンニャー
サンニャーの場合はそうとか
で で この感じたそうですが
ちょっと 仏教の解釈は少々違うんです
ブッダのテキストにしても
ものすごく説明すごく長いんです
そこら辺では で サンニャーっていうのは感じたものはについて何か区別するために
印みたいなもの生まれちゃうんです
何を感じたかっていうふうな感じで
一つのブックマークみたいに
こういうものだと ただ言葉にならないんです
言葉ではない いわゆる感じたものの
ヴェーダナーで感じたものの区別ですね
随分随分説明しないとしないと理解しにくい働きなんです
こういうこと 例えば私が人を見る
生まれて初めて目を開けて見た瞬間
触れる その情報 触れた情報は感じる
感じた瞬間でサンニャーが生まれる
そのサンニャーっていうのは
その触れた情報は何が違うかという
その違うところなんですね
それで私は目を閉じて
また目を開けて同じ人を見ると
すぐあの人だとわかるんですよ
あの人ですよとわかるために
私は前のサンニャー使うんです
ですから サンニャーっていうのは記憶には何とか関係ある働きなんです
我々の勉強というのは知識っていうのはサンニャーなんです
で 勉強するっていうことは
この区別できるということなんですね
例えば英語を勉強したっていうことは
耳に入る音について何か判断できるようになりましたと
英語がわからない人にとっては
英語を喋ったとしてもただの音だけ
そのサンニャーっていうものはすっと生まれるんです
確実に生まれる 何か見たらすぐそこにサンニャーが生まれる
何か聞いたらすぐサンニャーが生まれる
それで後でもよく結構使うんです
サンニャーの経験を ですから
しるしですね これは心が心に必要なしるしをつけちゃう
知覚と言っては違います
知ること 覚えることだけ知覚
知覚の際  知覚って何ですかね
記憶とやっぱり近い感じでしょうか
似ているかもしれませんだけど
全然この仏教の世界の言葉とは
こちらとは全く合わないんです
だから 古くからそういうふうに分析した人がいませんだから
仏教の心理学の世界の言葉はなかなか合わない
知覚っていうのは 我々にとってはものすごく膨大な働きの働きであって
ある一つのものではないんです
似ていると覚えるものは覚えはいますけど
いつでも生まれるということを
例えば皆様阿比達磨のテキストを持っている
テキストは物体として見るとほとんど似ているものなんです
でも 自分のテキストはちゃんと区別できるんですね
一緒にまとめておいても
これは私のテキスト これは私のテキストと区別できる
それはサンニャーの働き
それであまりにも似ていて区別できない場合
我々は強引にでも区別する
例えば自分の名前を書いている
その時は他のテキストとこれ違うんです
そこでサンニャーが 例えば買ったばっかしの本を持ってきて
3冊ぐらい 3人にあげると
あなたの本は確実に持ちなさいと言っても
その本 3冊と一緒になっちゃったら
どっちかわからなくなっちゃうんですね
いわゆるサンニャーが足らないんです
後で判断するために そこで自分の名前書いておいたら
そこで十分なサンニャーが生まれる
それでこれは私の本だとわかっちゃう
で 全く似ている 例えば双子がいるんだと
それは普通の人が見たところで
どちらかどっちかとわからなくなっちゃうんですね
なぜわからなくなっちゃうかというと
サンニャーが生まれるんだけど
Aさん見て生まれたサンニャーとBさんが見て生まれたサンニャーっていうのは
印はつけちゃったんだけど
印比べてみるとほぼ似ていて
それで頭が混乱しちゃう
勉強するっていうことは
このサンニャー自体が明確にする
そこで双子の場合だったら
いろいろ工夫して どちらかと区別するために工夫する
工夫が成功したらもうちゃんと知っている
失敗したらちゃんと知らない
勉強するということは
大体そういうふうにサンニャー自体を明確にするということなんです
記憶ということともまた違う
関係はあると初めから言った中に
記憶という言葉はアビダンマではない
記憶はサンニャーの働きで我々は考えているんです
記憶の分析的なものになるものがサンニャー
サンニャーっていうのはいつでも生まれる
でもサンニャーも様々だから
このしっかりしたサンニャーには我々は記憶と呼ぶんです
しっかりしていないサンニャーは
また思い出すことは不可能ですから
記憶と言わない 仏教だったらサンニャーが生まれたんだから
思い出そうすれば思い出せるということなんです
だから例えば我々の一時間の人生
一時間生きていると一時間いろんなことを経験する
それを全部覚えているかというと
全部覚えていない その中で派手なサンニャーが生まれたものだけ覚えておく
この 1時間以内で偶然
例えばどこか外人に会いましたと会っても言葉はわからなくて
いろいろ手で足で喋ったんだと
そうするとサンニャーがすごいんですね
それも忘れられない 忘れないんですね
で その間では部屋を見たりとか
空気に触れたりとか 喉を鳴らしたりとか
頭をかいたりとか いろんなことをしていたんだけど
一つも覚えてないんです
その時もサンニャーが生まれたんですけど
サンニャーのこの印がそれほど強烈じゃない
インプレッション  インプレッションですね
だからサンニャーはインプレッションですよ
この英語ではどんな でいろいろ説明して
このこのテキストでは Therefore サニャ Therefore means simple sense perception と書いてあるんですね
ですから おっしゃった通りに知覚なんですけど
すごい基本的な単純な知覚
一番基本的 それ育てると知識になるんです
絵を見ただけで サンニャーシンプル基本的なインプレッションが生まれるだけで
それはよくよく見ると
きめ細かく丁寧に よく見るともうすごい知識が生まれる
ですから 繰り返すことによって似ているサンニャーがたくさん生まれると
そこで力が強くなっちゃうんですね
この勉強というと 繰り返しはそういうわけなんです
単語を勉強する時でも繰り返して繰り返して言うと
サンニャーが生まれて生まれて生まれて同じものが生まれるとすぐ区別できるようになってしまう
で 一般的にはサンニャーってそういうふうな理解でいいんです
で 例えば私はチョーク一つ持ってきて皆さんに見せたら
見せた瞬間にサンニャーがもう生まれてるんです
でもそのサンニャーだけで明確だったら
もう二度とこのチョーク見たらすぐわかるはずなんです
でもそんなに明確じゃないんだから ２
回目見るともうわからないかもしれません
そこでいろんなチョークの中にこれ入れて
またこれ発見しようと思うと
我々は明確にそれ見ておかなくちゃいけない
だけど それをその人の勉強する方法にもなるんですね
だから勉強できる人っていうのは
この他のものとこれを区別するために何が何が違うかって
そこを探せば  じゃあ先生
五感を使うってことですか
うん 五感 六感 五感みたいなもので六感も使わなくちゃいけないんです
目で見るだけじゃなくて
触ってみることでもいいし
いろいろまあどっちでもいいんです
聞いてみたくてもです
ただ 同じチョークを二つ割って
同じ形のものを見せてあげて
これまたチョーク箱に入れますよ
また発見してくださいと
これを発見してくださいと言ったら
例えば私の場合は 僕はどうしますかというと
この割れてる割れ目を見るんです
じゃあこちらはこうなって
こちらはこうなってるんだと
それで覚えておくんです
ここら辺は真ん中の方は見ない
なぜならば全く同じだから
そうすると まあ箱に入れたところで
その自分が似たところで割れ目がこうやってなってるとか
これですよと 一番わかりやすいといえば
ここにペンで何か点でも入れておくとかね
すると自分入れた点があるものを探せるんだ
簡単に それがサンニャーなんですね
勉強するっていうこと
そういうことなんです
で 単語の勉強すると 同じ単語を繰り返して繰り返して
自分で言う 頭の中で言う
そうすると 1つ訓練になる
それから喋ってみる そうすると自分使うし
自分の耳で聞くし そこでいろんな同じものについてたくさんサンニャーが生まれる
いわゆる一つの単語について
目から入ったデータがいっぱいある
耳から入ったデータがいっぱいある
あるいはその単語を聞いたところで体験もさせたならば
そうすると体から入ったデータもいっぱいある
自分が一人で考えたこともあるならば
知識 あの 考えたデータも残ってる
そうするとあの単語すぐ聞いたらすぐこれだと
検索しやすい すごい簡単に検索しやすい風にサンニャーが作れば見つかる
図書館の例で言うならば
図書館で本 図書館に一冊入れたらカード作っちゃうんですね
たった一枚のカードだけ作っちゃうと
なかなかその本は見つからないんです
そうするとカードたくさん作る
一つ オーサーですか 書いた人の名前ありますね
その名前のカード作る
名前三つあるんだったらカード三つ作る
タイトルにも言葉が四つあるんだったら
そのカード四つ作る それからこの本はどんなカテゴリーかと
哲学か宗教か政治学かどっちかと
そのカテゴリーに入れてカード作る
それで 一冊の本についてカードは五
六枚 七 八枚があるんです
で 私は二番目 その本は探したんだけど
このタイトル忘れちゃった
オーサーの名前を忘れちゃったんだけど
おそらくなんとかなんとかサイモンでしたねと思っちゃう
そうするとどこで探せば見つかっちゃう
あるいは出版した年代でカードを作ったならば
これはあれは去年二月出た本だからと思ったら
そうすると去年二月出た本はどれぐらいあるかと
そこで探せば見つかる
本は一つですけど カードはたくさんある
勉強っていうのは そういうふうに一つのものについていろんな情報を作るんです
いろんなチャンネルで
例えば英語を日本でいくら勉強したっても
みんな外国に行って アメリカに行って
タイに行って 半年間行くと
また同じ英語の単語について
またいろんな情報が入りますから
それで上手にできるようになっちゃうと
いわゆる検索早くするようになったということ
そういう働きは全部サンニャーの働き
その時我々は知らないうちにサンニャーに集中しているんです
これサンニャーと誰もわからない
そうだと ただ勉強しているんだ
反復しているんだと 英語がよくできるようにホームステイしているんだとというだけのことに
英語できるのはホームステイしちゃうと
まあいろんな体験できる
食べる時も同じ単語が入っちゃうし
寝る時も同じ単語 だから食べることも寝ることは歩くこと
日常いろんな自分 他のサンニャーでよく知ってることをやって
それとあの比べてすぐわかるようになるんです
知覚の世界ですね パーセプション
でもアビダンマではそんな大胆な働きというよりは
基本的な このそれを主のレベルで何が起こるかと
いわゆる目に何か情報が入ったその瞬間でサンニャーは作ってるんです
いわゆる感じたら何を感じたかもう区別しているんです
区別しない 聞く見えないんです
ですから認識します 区別するっていうことで
その経験みんなにあるんです
例えば今 私の話をずっと聞いていると
でも耳にはいろんな情報が入るんですよ
いろんな音も入るんだけど
その情報は区別しない
サンニャー作ろうとしない
ですから聞こえてない
で 私の話を耳に入るにも関わらず
いや 外の音を聞こうと思っちゃったらすぐ聞こえるんです
で 何かやると他のことがわからなくなっちゃうんですよ
体には触れてるんだけど
銃も銃鳴らなかったらどうしようもないんだけどね
一応サンニャーは作れない時はもう知らない
とにかくこの区別は大変大事な働き
すごく難しいんですけど
これなぜ大事かということ
一応とりあえずこの簡単に理解していきましょう
眼耳鼻舌身意という六つに
触れる色声香味触法という情報が触れるたびに
それはどんなものか どんなものか
どんなものかと その違うところはつかまる
この違うところつかまることによって
認識の働きが生まれるんです
違うとことつかまらなかったら認識は生まれません
我々は常に物事を認識しているんだから
常にサンニャー作ってるんです
それはどんな生命にも同じです
その中で一部の生命は勉強したり
あるサンニャーがわさわさ作ったりして
いろんなことをする それだけの差があるんです
ですから 人間にとってはサンニャー
生命にとってはサンニャーっていうのはもう一番すごい大事な働き
生きてるっていうことは
外の世界を認識するっていうことだから
区別しなきゃ認識できませんから
常にやっている ですから
自分の存在とほとんど同じものなんです
だから我々は私だと誤解するのは
このサンニャーひとつ
ヴェーダナーひとつ 感じること自体
私が感じたということでなっちゃうし
サンニャーについても私と誤解しちゃうんです
だから仏教の自分というものは五蘊に分けるんですね
ルーパ ヴェーダナー サンニャー
サンカーラ ヴィンニャーナ
それでルーパは色 物体
物体はよく分かりやすい
五蘊の場合は塊５つに分けて
一つは物質的な塊 もう一つは感じること
もう一つはサンニャーなんです
それぐらい大胆な働きなんです
五蘊の中の一つ  うん そうそう
五蘊の中の一つなんです
サンニャー いくらかでも理解しなきゃ本当に困りますけどね
そこら辺は 何がサンニャーですか
なんか実験でもしてね
どう 実験は簡単ですけどね
何か 2つのものを見る
同時に 見て 見た瞬間にサンニャー生まれてるんですよ
それで他のどうかは置いといて
その 2つをまた二度と区別してみる
自分に聞いてみる 簡単です
例えばこの空き缶を見る
それから眼鏡を見る 空き缶見ると
空き缶についてサンニャーが生まれる
眼鏡を見ると眼鏡についてサンニャーが生まれる
じゃあ私は皆様に聞きます
空き缶とメガネはどのように区別しますかと
言うと言葉使ってるんだから無茶苦茶なことを言うかもしれませんだけど
言葉なしに区別できるんですね
空き缶は鉄で作ってるんだとか
丸くて長いんだとかね
メガネはこういう透明なガラスあるなとか言うかもしれませんだけど
その以前 これも区別しているんです
その区別能力がサンニャなんです
だから言葉とか関係ないんです
そこで同じ缶ジュース
同じものが 2つあって
で 私はその 2つ持って見せて
じゃあ区別してくださいって言ったら
ちょっと区別不可能なんです
サンニャを作ったから作ったんだけど
左手で持った缶と右手で持った缶から生まれたサンニャは全く似ているんだから
もうわからない 区別できない
ですから区別できないサンニャだから思い出せないサンニャ
記憶力に関係ないサンニャ
あるいは紙 1枚持ってきて
2つに割ると 割ってみたら
すぐ左手の紙と右手の紙について 2つのサンニャが生まれるんです
それで区別できる 区別できない場合はいろいろ工夫する
紙を割って この紙の場合は上の紙はどっち？下の紙はどっちで
例えば A4 の紙を持ってきて
綺麗に 2つに折ってから切ったならば
どちらが上の紙か どちらが下の紙
区別できないでしょう
その場合は なぜかあるサンニャのエネルギーは足らない
でも 区別あるはずなんです
紙の場合は表はどっちか
裏がどっちかというと
その紙によりますけど
区別できない 私にもたまに今の紙ありますね
ワープロで薄いリボンいらない
このタイム カンラス よく失敗するんです
印刷しない方が入れたりして
もう待って待って 結局もう何にも真っ白
それは裏と表が区別できなかったんだと
それで 2回  2回  3回失敗したんだから
もうあれからたって紙を入れる前に
私は 2つにちょっと折ってみるんです
いわゆる入れてみれば
印刷する側が白くて 裏側はそんなに白くない
そこで区別できる 普通に見ると全く真っ白なんですよ
でもくらってみると この印刷できる部分はより白い
そこでサンニャがこちらが印刷面だと思って入れて
ちゃんと無事に解決すると
今カラープリンター印刷する場合でも
やっぱり印刷面が決まってるんです
こっちのこの面も印刷面だと
その時も同じ裏表同じ白だから分からなくなっちゃう
分からなくなると折ってみる
それ私のやり方ですけど
皆様は触ってみるかどっちか分かりませんだけど
たまに触ってみる時もありますね
触ってみて スルスルしている面は裏で表でスルスルしてない面は表の裏ですよと
それでも指の感覚は鋭くなければダメですよ
その場合は だからいろいろ工夫してしっかりしたサンニャを作ればもう OK ということになっちゃう
そういうのはサンニャの働き
我々は知らないうちにいつでもそんなことやってるんです
そういうのは特別サンニャの働き使ってるだけで特別に
でも普通に普段サンニャが生まれているんです
例えば紙を見たところで
裏を見て表見ると ちゃんとその光の情報入ってるはずなんです
でもまあ論観だから 私の場合はもう知識の方が白いやつ
すぐ簡単に決めてしまっちゃう
そうするとどっちが裏表か分からなくなっちゃう
そうするとさらに工夫しなくちゃいけない
鋭い人は見ただけこれは裏
これは表だと合うかもしれません
感覚が鋭い そういう風にこのサンニャって働きは常に我々にあるもの
あまり使ってて あまり自分だとアイデンティティ作ってるんだから
業の中で想蘊と言ってるんです
それはただのサンニャだよと
魂でも私でも何でもないんだよと仏教で言ってるんです
サンニャっていうのは瞬間瞬間新しいサンニャが生まれる
サーンニャーがたくさん生まれた人はたくさんの経験がある人で
少ない人は経験少ないし
それでサーンニャー自体も忘れちゃうしね
全部覚えてるわけじゃないし
工夫しちゃったら明確になっちゃうし
工夫しなかったら全然明確にならないし
勉強上手な人っていうのはサーンニャーの方で工夫する人
ただ聞いたばっかりで勉強にならないでしょうに
もう生かしてじゃあ聞いてやろうというから真面目に聞いて
そんなサーンニャーは生まれません
それで それも自分でもこのことを考えたりとか
また読み直したりとかすると
サーンニャーが鋭くなって
勉強になったということになるんです
で 私は個人的に言うなれば
このいろんな勉強して
今は勉強してないんだけど
勉強してた時はもうずっと話聞いてる瞬間でもありとあらゆる工夫してるんだよ
頭の中で いろんな論理構想を頭の中で作って
その中で考えたりとか
その人が言うことは本当にそうかと自分の論理で考えたり
あるいはそれの何か反論でもないかとか
それも考えたりとか その途中で話も聞いたりとか
そうすると話を聞いていると同時に膨大なサーンニャーの量が生まれているんです
心ってのは早く動くんだから
喋る場合ゆっくり喋ってるんだから
そうすると言ってることはもうわかってるんですね
もう覚えてるんですよ
じゃあサーンニャーですね
これくらいにして 次のチェータナ
チェータナっていうのはまた
意思です 何かエネルギー生まれちゃうんです
サーンニャーしたところで
何かこうしようああしようっていう風なように
この意思が生まれる この普通の言ってる意思というよりは
すごい基本的な根本的で
何かしたくなるような微かなエネルギーが生まれる
それは膨大化すれば 私の意思はこうこうなることやと言うかもしれませんだけど
でも瞬間瞬間にも意思っていうものはあるんです
何かしたくなるんです
それにはエネルギーなんですよ
いつでも何かしたいでしょ
見たい 聞きたいとか なんとかなると
綺麗に止まりたいという気持ちはないのか
この意志は仏教でカルマと言うんです
仏教でカルマ業というのはこの意志なんです
ですから このある生命が何か認識した瞬間に意志も生まれるんです
この意志自体がちょっとでもわずかでも強くなっちゃったら
それはカルマ 業なんです
いわゆる心の一つの揺らぎなんですね
で 次にあるのはエーカグタ
エーカグタなんですが
一境性とか言ってるんですけど
一境性 まあエーカグタっていうのは
この見る 聞く 味わうものにその瞬間集中するんですね
この瞬間の集中なんです
それは分かりやすい 例えば何か壁を見る場合は
壁を見たいと思って すぐ自分の意志がそこに集中しちゃう
その瞬間に見える だから私の音を聞いている時でも
瞬間でも 外の音に集中しちゃったら外の音を聞こえちゃう
集中しなきゃそれは聞こえない
これ 集中力と言えるものじゃないんです
すごい基本的な働きで
でも集中しなきゃ認識は生まれません
我々の問題は この集中力はもういろんなところに走り回ってるだけ
ここで勉強しているんだけど
心がいろんなところに走っている
だから集中力はないという
それは １箇所に止まれないということに
俗的な俗世間で集中力というんです
ある一つの対象にとどまっているならば集中力はあるんですね
ある一箇所にとどまってもとどまらなくても
我々は見る 認識するたびに
そこに集中力という集中というのがあるんです
集中力がないかもしれませんだけど
集中して本を読むということは
他の情報に気がいかないで
本だけに自分の気が付いているということ
その働きにエーカグタというんです
それも我々は育てるんでしょう
サンニャーと同じく サンニャー育てるとよく頭が良くて
もうしっかり勉強できて
知識はものすごい抜群
チェータナ育ちちゃうとものすごくこの行動的であれやろう
これやろう あーだこーだとかね
まあいろんなことをやりたくなっちゃうし
エーカグタ我々は育てちゃうんですよ
集中力 それを育てるとサンニャーは明確で行動力が抜群になっちゃうんです
いろんなことをやりたいんだけど
集中できない人にそれできないでしょ
ピアノもやりたい 踊りもやりたい
数字もやりたいですけど
集中しないと一つもできなくなっちゃう
だからこのチェータナだけあっても行動はできないし
集中力だけあっても行動はできないし
そこで集中力も作る で
一番 例えば子供の場合は集中力
子供に一番集中力ないんですね
いろんなものに気がいっちゃいますから
ですから 一番勉強しにくい
小さな子供 そこで教育システムでは
まあ子供くらいの心はわかってるんだから
みんな子供の興味を出るような
いろんな工夫をする それで子供にとって面白い
面白いんだから あっちこっち集中力いかないで
集中がいかないで それだけに行っちゃう
数え方を教える場合は
１  2  3  4と言ったって
子供は勉強してくれない
その代わりに まあいろんなおもちゃを持ってきて
これは１つとこれと 2つですよと
例えばぬいぐるみを 2つ持って
子供はぬいぐるみにおもしろい
そうすると これと１つと
もう一つぬいぐるみを持てば
これ 2つだよと言ったら
ぬいぐるみが面白いんだから
そこに集中する そうすると
1つと 2つということを勉強してしまっちゃうんです
そういうふうに強引に集中力作っちゃう
大人もそういうふうに
この何かに集中したければ
強引にものをやること面白がらないと集中力は生まれてこない
で 瞑想 特にサマーディ瞑想でやらせるのはこの集中力の訓練なんです
サマーディというのは
この集中力が抜群に成長した状態なんです
何がなくても集中していると
というのは本当にすごいサマーディなんです
ですから集中しちゃったら他のものは知らない
聞かない 感じない